I could play the most amazing game in
the world today but the internet would
hate me for telling them about it
great everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel today I am going to an event
in San Francisco to get hands-on time
with Metal Gear survives single-player
and co-op mode a preview event is not
particularly out of the ordinary for my
job writing about video games at IGN but
playing a game that everyone already
hates is an interesting experience as
media going into this preview event I
want to have no bias and I don't have a
lot of bias towards this game I'm trying
to approach it as objectively as
possible but fact is it would be easier
for me to cover this game in a negative
light than in a positive life and that
is a weird thing to go into an event
knowing I'm not gonna let that influence
my writing but I kind of wanted to
document the process of what it's like
as a journalist to cover a controversial
game maybe it'll be terrible and it'll
all be easy I'm expecting it to be
average and therefore the preview is
going to be hard because I'm going to
say some things that might be positive
and people are gonna be mad but let's
stop talking for now I gotta head to the
event got about 5 hours of play time so
let's go
okay you guys I'm still at the event but
I put in about two hours so far and this
is more or less what I expected it's not
what I expected in terms of a game it's
a survival game I didn't expect that
based on gameplay that I've looked up
before I was expecting sort of survival
elements but also like a left4dead style
game it's absolutely not that it's you
with a base leaving the base to go find
stuff in a open world that it's very
unforgiving with hunger and stamina
means that you have to watch and enemies
that a little bit of a pain and about to
kill because the combats a little clunky
but yeah I have positive things to say I
think the progression system is quite
interesting and I think that while I
haven't played it the late game for this
game is probably quite good I think the
early game has a lot of flaws and of
course you know I'm going to write about
all of this but this is just almost a
crushing moment where of course I never
want any game to be bad I want all games
to be good but when it comes to
something like this where I'm always
going to go with what I think is correct
rather than what the audience wants me
to say the fact that I'm not going to
speak about this game 100% negatively is
going to make the next week hotter so
I've got the weekend to think about it
to go over my notes to take a look at
the gameplay we recorded and start
putting things together but I probably
won't start writing until actually next
week so see you guys then hello everyone
I hope you all had a happy weekend today
we are back in the IGN office check this
cool [ __ ] out and I'm going to start
writing my metal gear preview like I
said the goal here is objectivity so I'm
writing a lot of really informational
stuff which is what previews are I also
have stuff about how managing your food
and water and metal gear survive at
least initially is a little more than
tedious which was in pot actually
written by another one of our producers
James Duggan what's up everybody James
Duggan joining me is Alanna Pierce we
are here to discuss to be much-loved
Metal Gear survive we got some hands-on
time with the preview van okay and I
kind of went into this without a ton of
bias I have to say I was not impressed
by any egg what about you i alternate
Lee think that there is a market for
this I don't think it's
despite you know people expecting that
it's probably not for a lot of people
that definitely isn't metal gear and for
someone who wants metal gear is probably
going to be disappointed there are very
very few references to even metal gear
but it's not it's not the worst thing
I'm sure I think that's a pretty
objective fair reading I have to say I
agree I've said stuff about how the
resource management works and how its
kind of unforgiving but also about how
crafting and progression some of my most
positive takeaways from metal gear
survive so ultimately I'm trying to
explain a lot about the game and the
different facets of things that I saw
and based on my initial impressions
whether I like them or not but for the
most part I am trying to not give a ton
of opinion here all right you guys I'm
just about to publish the preview the
embargo is midnight meaning I've had to
wait up actually by myself to publish
this one this doesn't normally happen
this is a weird circumstance but I'm
just about to publish it and I'm
expecting even though I was largely
negative for people to be furious at me
so let's see shall we
all right yeah some people command there
are some people who is saying thank you
for being objective which is awesome but
this is ultimately the same trend that I
saw when I said negative things about no
man's sky before it came out people
tried to get me fired the same thing
happened with Mass Effect Andromeda
people were furious at me for saying
negative things about a game that they
really wanted to like this just creates
an interesting conflict and
misconception people think that games
journalists care about what publishers
think a publisher has never gotten mad
at me for reviewing anything negatively
they've never even said a word to me but
people on the Internet much scarier much
was things happened to people will be
internet but I really wanted to showcase
what this is like because I think a lot
of people don't really realize it's not
something that makes me want to stop
doing my job or anything like that
either just something that I hope people
think about all righty you guys thank
you so much for watching I will see you
all next time